I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will the mad Kings daughter will
destroy the realm we must stand together
if we hope to stop her we can't defeat
night Kings army on our own Daenerys has
Dragon Fire a Targaryen cannot be
trusted if we don't band together we
will die
Wednesday it is your great everyone is
your enemy
everyone is your friend
every possible series of event is
happening all at once
I believe you have a role to play as
does another
happy comic-con week continues they just
dropped a new trailer for Game of
Thrones it's extended and they're just a
couple shots from episode three it's
mostly for Episode two though so it's
kind of like an extended trailer they
might release another one during their
panel so be sure to subscribe to get
that obviously I'm doing Game of Thrones
videos all season long but let's just go
to this shop by shot starting with the
biggest thing first we knew that people
would be visiting Daenerys to
Dragonstone Jon Snow has to learn about
the dragon glass so eventually he's
going to go there but it's Melisandre
who gets there first
we actually speculated based on the
episode titles like Daenerys receives a
visitor and I think it was from episode
2 so it's like way too soon for Jon Snow
to make it there so when we saw
Melisandre on the cliff face in the
trailer here we're like oh ok so it's
probably her that goes there first
because she's been exiled from Jon
Snow's presence but now we see beerus
walk up in brain so it's just her coming
to Daenerys trying to explain the war
for the dawn to her so you see how Game
of Thrones is table setting for future
episodes it's going to explain all the
mythology of what's going on north of
the wall to Daenerys through MELAS
Andrews character before Jon Snow and
arrives asking for help in that war so
she's not like wait a minute what the
hell are you talking about what's the
white Walker
she doesn't look dumb when Jon Snow
rolls up but there's a whole bunch of
other stuff going on here the Lannister
army looks fantastic when they're in
formation this is spectacular and
there's just a lot of stuff that looks
like it's happening at Casterly Rock
it's probably from episode 3 there's
just way too much stuff going on because
it seems like most of what's happening
at Winterfell in next week's episode is
Daenerys specific so shot by shot we
just get some repeats from the last
trailer that we saw for episode to
Daenerys talking about being born to
rule the Seven Kingdoms then you finally
find out who's Circe's talking to it's
the tarly's and you see the recast
version of dick and Tarly the actor who
played and during season six went on
another TV show which has since been
cancelled so they had to recast the role
so now it seems like samwell's father's
going to be fighting for Cersei and the
Lannisters he actually fought for the
Targaryens during Robert's rebellion
losing side now it also seems like he's
probably going to make the bad
but it provides some nice steaks for
Samwell in the same way that Tyrion is
somewhat torn about destroying his
family like he loves Jaime even though
he probably hates Cersei he might not
want to roast her with dragon fire at
the first opportunity he just given
pause in his viciousness so we'll see
how that plays out family against family
but then you see the people of
Winterfell training like Jon Snow told
them to do in the first episode put a
bow arrow and weapon in the hand of
every man woman and child this is almost
like one of those moments where you let
the air out of a balloon because they
can barely hit the target they're trying
to show you that even though everyone's
on board with Jon Snow trying to get
ready for what's coming with the night
king they're just completely unprepared
like no matter how much they train
they're not going to be enough they
absolutely have to get to nearest his
help in Jon Snow says Dragon Fire I love
the way that he specifies that he
doesn't say dragonglass but we're only
getting part of a scene so maybe he got
the Raven from Samwell but I love the
way they chose to include that line
about the Dragons specifically Yan Royce
is like hell no we can't trust
Targaryens and you see Littlefinger sort
of smiling in the background like oh I
can use this I can use everyone's
natural fear of the Targaryen to tear
this alliance apart you see this
reaction on Santa's face so maybe she
just slips a little at the idea of a
line with the Targaryens but you don't
really get a sense for what's going on
in her brain when Littlefinger has all
those lines about fighting the battle
all over the place in your mind so it
looks like that's where that speech
happens where he's like you need to play
three-dimensional chess the game of
Thrones is much bigger and much more
complicated than you think
you see you're on rolling up into King's
Landing this is probably from episode
three after the big Greyjoy battle
they're talking about in episode two the
sand I and grey worm also getting it on
and it looks like the action that Theon
and Yara are witnessing is something
from the middle of that big battle next
week this Arya shot looks like it's
still from episode 2 you see more of the
Lannister battle at Casterly Rock with
the unsullied
that's probably episode three we've
already seen a lot of those shots from
the previous trailers and then you see a
better shot of Jamie walking into what
looks like Highgarden so I would say
that all these shots of Lannisters and
formations seeming bare
powerful that's from the high guard and
stuff this unsullied stuff is from way
up north and Casterly Rock in a
completely different episode but I love
these beautiful Denair shots of her
outdoors on that stairway they say a lot
of the scenes were filmed out here this
year just because Dragonstone is so dark
inside and typically we've seen Daenerys
outside like metaphorically you see
Cersei in these really dark corridors
it's meant to imply much darker tone
Daenerys is a much more positive
storyline at least right now so you see
her outside a lot in the bright light of
day except for this Melisandre scene I
love the way they use life to implied
tone and scenes but all in all I am just
really excited the idea of your on
smashing Daenerys is fleet and what is
going to happen with all of MELAS
Andrews interactions in the characters
at Dragonstone like Varys looks like he
is very wary of her he totally
understands what's going on but like he
says he absolutely detests all forms of
magic and that's what Melisandre
represents he represents the
supernatural force but I think in the
way that the northerners like Yan Royce
really hate the idea of Daenerys
embarrass really hates the idea of magic
they'll all be crossing the aisle a
little bit recognizing that they need
something that these other characters
can provide so I wouldn't be surprised
that Varys tries to keep Melisandre at
arm's length but also listens to what
she has to say says okay you're talking
about things that I know to be true even
though I may not have seen them myself
the same way that Samwell is talking to
the maester down in the Citadel his line
actually sort of tells you what a lot of
these interactions are going to be like
in these other storylines where he sort
of discounts what Samwell as saying like
okay the wall has always stood there's
no reason to think that it won't but
because you keep harping on the idea of
White Walkers in the army of the Dead
you're probably right you're probably
telling the truth so the archmaester
Ebro scene is sort of a template for a
lot of these other scenes Targaryen how
dare you say we ally with them cut to
okay you know maybe that's not such a
bad idea
we could probably listen to what they
had to say but it's going to be great
I'm expecting that when episode two
drops and they drop another trailer for
episode three there'll be some different
footage but what's going to happen is
there's a whole bunch more trailers that
will be dropping later tonight like
defenders and Punisher so just look out
for that stuff as long as you
Alerts turned on you'll get all of it if
they drop anything new at the game of
Thrones comic-con panel I'll do a video
for it but new Game of Thrones coming on
Sunday either way so congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Shane Swift
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here to learn
all about the secrets of dragonglass and
what was on those pages that Samwell was
reading there's a lot of information
they convey and you can click here for
my episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you